just what I'd expect from YouTube next
[Music]
victory what's the point of stealing
hearts and acing exams if you can't look
stylish doing it donning the threads of
thieves and the fashionable uniforms of
shoe gin hi are a couple reasons why
persona 5 is so I poppin lis gorgeous if
you still need to be convinced of
Atlas's fashion consciousness look no
further than the studio's growing
collection of costume DLCs just in the
first two weeks alone we've been treated
to school uniforms from previous persona
games and even shin megami tensei if
have you fantasized what on would look
like if she went to the same school as
we say now you can see for yourself
better yet these period uniforms have
throwback battle music to match
[Music]
and this DLC showcase wouldn't be a
complete nostalgia trip unless we had
some retro personas to complement these
throwback duds so if you miss the
magical assists from the likes of
Orpheus and Thanatos they're obtainable
at the PSN store for a price of a cup of
coffee for costumes and music that's
more like a small lunch check out the
rest of this gameplay showcase as we
cycle through all these DLC outfits plus
some handy personas from the previous
games if you enjoyed this gameplay and
want to see more persona 5 DLCs give us
a like and subscribe to our youtube
channel thanks for watching
[Music]
yeah she's got a sec from you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
like us Luiza Nagi picker Oh
you're mine Joker a spectacular victory
[Music]
[Music]
Matsui Zanardi pickerel
[Music]
picker Oh
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[ __ ]
only one more let's go
[Music]
Sona
[Music]
I got syriza Nagi pick her up
[Music]
we remained
one
Oh